all right we got another edition of a
beginner breakdown tonight I am your
host Mike comer a very special edition
tonight we got games that end in eight
moves so if you think you're really good
at chess you can say hey I could beat
you in eight moves and then here's the
proof all right so here's a the first
game I was playing on the Internet HAMB
HAMB HAMB II against Graceland hammies
got whiteness let's see how he or she
does all right III be five you should
always be starting out with E for all
right that's your first mistake
and then Queen to h5 attacks the pivotal
f7 square so the knight comes out and
attacks the Queen as we know this is not
good because the Queen can take down
defend a pawn Queen takes Czech Bishop
the e7 so now the knight comes out to f3
got to get another piece involved so if
you were playing black in this position
what would you do here and know that you
don't want to lose an eight moves right
so what we got what do you think a good
player would play in this position for
black so yeah you got a lot of options
knight c6 attack the Queen d6 attack the
Queen or you could simply Castle and be
like I'm not getting checkmate moves
there's nothing you can do about it but
yeah it's more fun to attack right all
right all right so so you guys didn't
pick any of the ways then you can
actually attack this Queen we shout out
d6 96 but the little known Knight to g4
all right so now the Queen is under
attack all right so this is great
there's an undefended pawn let's take
now if you were to bet which side is
going to lose and eight moves I bet you
it picked the wrong and
sir all right so they've got to do
something about this ruck so let's see
if we figure out a way to defend the
rook by not moving it oh man that's a
tough one it's a tough one it's you're
like what it's like an x-ray okay bishop
sees through the Queen and protects the
rook he sees this so he's like oh I
can't take the rook cuz the bishop would
take me right well but he sees that so
he's really good he's like but I got a
knight here I can just take it for free
and I'm doing great all right so now
he's like I got a trick up my sleeve
I just I just play d6 you know no
nothing to worry about what should you
be worried about
do you know Mario if you were white what
were you would you be worried about
right now who's under attack doc Queen
discovered he yeah good
so he's like check and now Bishop to e7
and now all the whites hard work is just
crushed
cuz he's like I see this pawn I'll take
it not so good
cuz the bishop protects the square so
he's like up I lost so don't take pieces
that are defended okay pretty simple all
right so so grace' played a great game
one in eight moves it's like II planned
all right so now Grayson has the black
pieces here in another eight move
encounter alright so we'll see see it
from Grayson's point of view so b4 b5
sometimes called the orangutan where
they bring out the bishop here and say
he just offends the pawn all right fair
enough
and now Grayson's going for
big center excellent hey just keeps
pushing these ponds and now Grayson
can't resist it he's like he could he
could just play another great like
developing move you know but instead
he's they are and I challenge this so he
brings out his knight to defend it
and we all know the big trick remove the
defender we could just play d5
now this Knight has to go away and we
could win a pawn okay but you know
that's not the spirit of this so Bishop
to c5 attacking f2 very interesting well
notice that these F 2 and F 7 squares
very weak ok so it's like ok for you
pulling once again it's not free right
you can take what is like you know
what's better than taking free Knights
threatening checkmate now which is
better in reality threatening a
checkmate yet can be easily solved with
g3 or taking a piece for free take the
piece because you're playing hope chest
you're hoping that you know he's not
gonna see Queen takes up to checkmate or
even Bishop takes up to check me all
right we don't have to play g3 we can
play uh III all right maybe he was
hoping that he would play g3 cuz after
g3 to stop this mate you get a super
fort going on alright you could just be
like Shaq King takes Queen check and
take the rook you can do all kinds of
cool stuff or you could just take the
night and be up on the height that's
recommended okay so Queen to h4 was
played so is like I got this III no
problem so it's now he's like attacking
the knight
all right so the night has a really good
move in this position can anybody see it
good moves are usually checks and
captures sometimes threats so what we
got does white have a really good check
night to see seven check King has to
move and you took the rook game over
blacks never coming back from this
deficit in this in this in this position
you wouldn't resign you would probably
take the pawn and then you know you can
try to get this this night here somehow
some way it's pretty easy if I go here
you know there you know maybe he's got a
good defense here hopefully you'll get
the night but if you don't then you can
resign but at least try to play on there
was no reason for him to resign in that
position so we all saw it black did he
didn't take free material and he went
for his own checkmate that was easily
stopped
so just take material when you can all
right next one Grayson once again has
the black pieces so we'll see how it
does here efore east six d4 now if
you've been watching who could predict
blacks move here who do you think blacks
gonna move it's gonna be a piece off the
back row can I have any guesses any
guesses Chris for excellent now you're
playing like Grayson alright I don't
know what that's a good thing or a bad
thing but you're playing like him
alright so the knight of three works
every time right but he doesn't even
want the free pond he sees he loves
check okay he loves check so this check
is a big mistake because even though
he's attacking the King now he's got one
piece on free meaning hanging
and now another piece hanging have you
ever heard that expression don't leave
me hangin bro it derived from chests
okay
so so that's what it means don't leave
them hanging alright so now what can he
do all he can do now is take check we
got a little Intermezzo going on here so
Queen takes e4 check and then now we
move this the safety so excellent
but then sit so Bishop takes c3 check
pawn takes and now he's like oh yeah
Queen takes check alright that all
Stephen it got a little darker in here
it's again scary very ominous hey all
right
but we'll uh we'll proceed Bishop e2 and
so now he goes and attacks the pawn so
if you were playing white what move
would you play now give you a hint
castle or attack the Queen see a castle
it's kind of scary I'm not gonna say
it's not scary but it's better than the
alternative so Knight to e5 so a double
attack on the Queen the Knights
attacking it and the bishop so after
Queen takes g2 he decides you know what
I attack the Queen the last move I'm
gonna attack them again rook the g-woman
not recommended because look it's not
protected by anybody and so that's it
eight moves Queen takes to you one game
over all right
all right Grayson's got the black pieces
again alright and now white starts out
this is not uh this isn't that a replay
of a game we already saw okay although
it look very similar and it ends in
eight moves obviously okay so III be
five okay so so now Grayson Grayson's
opponent Kyle Kyle is white place Queen
to f3
so now d5 Knight c3 double attacking the
pawn so he just attacks pawn takes pawn
takes check so block the check
everything's going great Knight to d5 so
so I don't see really any threats for
white so far in this position so he
attacks the night fair enough Knight
takes a 7 Knight takes a 7 so Kyle sees
that this pawn is undefended this
precious G pond and remember his 8th
move is coming up so where do you think
Kyle unfortunately places is Queen to
attack this pawn queen g4 right yep not
very good you can't put your pieces in
the same Lane as your opponent's okay
it's a bishop takes g4 and the game is
over okay
the next game we have here this is from
a totally new opponent Jan has the white
pieces against a chess Rubens thing I
think it's Harper Smith Rubinstein here
so let's see how I would submit the
Rubens thing does here all right so
white plays d4 black plays d5 so we're
getting a more natural looking up
position than before in these games the
Knight f3 attacks the pawn knight c6
protects now white decides to play a
very restrictive move here
d3 putting this bishop in a box here so
not not recommended so black casually
plays Knight f6 out here white continues
his development and black gets in d5
probably would have been a better idea
to get this Bishop out cc5 attacked f2
or even b4 but alright d5 it's a little
ambitious it could get them in trouble
here so Bishop the g5 pinning the Knight
takes e4 take c4 so Queen takes check
King takes d1 alright
so Bishop the g4 alright so if you were
playing white there's one really really
bad move that was unfortunately played
won't be able to find it maybe he was
reaching for the H pawn and accidentally
hit the huh this pawn so the worst move
for white in this position is played
instead of just playing a simple move
like Bishop e2 getting out of the pen he
reaches for a g3 and before he black can
even move he just throws his King in the
air and just give
sup so so obviously check and you just
lost two pieces for nothing
so never voluntarily remove the
defenders of your pieces okay not wise
alright we got one more eight mover here
and then I might get a game in and try
to try to show them what it's like here
alright so Jan has the white pieces in
this encounter
all right so II 4 E 5 Knight f3 Bishop
to c5 attacking f2 alright and now white
play is a very uh another bad move for
this Bishop okay we saw it in the
previous move d3 kind of hurt that fish
up but in this game they decided to put
their Bishop on d3 okay essentially
making this Bishop into a big pawn okay
where is B so much more happy on c4
attacking you know f7 okay so it needs
to work on that
alright so Queen to f6 threatening
nothing hoping you know it could happen
as we've seen well now we're gonna see a
move that we haven't seen in any of
these games so far can you guess what it
is
what a castle it's a a very foreign move
to these guys but you're going castle by
move forward that's excellent but just
because you're in a castle doesn't mean
that they're not going to be coming
after you
so Queen to g6 all right so now the
queen is in the same Lane as the enemy
king but hey free pawn Knight takes e5
so they want to stay in the line here so
Queen to g5 so they bring out their
Queen to f3 threatening threatening to
take on f7 with check alright so
so what move would you play to stop
queen takes f7 check here well I got a
really good move I guess you guys do too
right Queen takes the knight right that
looks pretty good it looks good to me
all right
so instead they're like I'm going to
attack that night all right so my
Knights under attack I better move it
that's what they're thinking all right
all right so so they do they move it and
now they got the fork and so they're are
so excited they got the fork so it's
like whenever wherever you move the
Queen it doesn't matter I'm gonna take
the rook okay so this happens a lot you
get so excited like I get I get a piece
I get a piece I don't care just make
your move move hurry up hurry up hurry
up move so I can take your rook I'm so
happy I got you're up yeah all right so
you gotta pay attention to where your
opponent's move even when they're moving
out of a fork okay all right because
they just created a threat way bigger
then your threat ever was so what move
does black play Queen takes a tree if
you wanted to end the game in eight
moves but if you want to torture your
opponent you're playing that but yeah
but here one of them win an eight move
so it went for the direct mate all right
so now I got to show everybody what it's
like okay you've seen a lot of eight
move games so how many moves do you
think it takes me to beat my opponent
here I might come around the state
champion come on seven bird time us.just
champion yeah so he got it right he
knows what he knows what it's about
okay so here I go so I gotta beat them
in seven moves all right so here we go
efore a 5 so Bishop c4 aim directly at
f7 here alright Bishop c5 now everybody
probably thinks I bring that queen out
here or here I'd like to do it with my
knight all right Knight f3
so Knight f6 so they let me go into this
this attack here so Knight to g5 but
it's that very good right because what
move can can black play to just get out
of this whole mess here castles
excellent alright so you know when you
see a good move you got to repeat it
right so castle castle and now black
makes a horrific blunder here all right
you see a lot of these unforced errors
in these games which they have no call
for okay so in this position for black
you know you could play a h6 here maybe
d6 knight c6 does anything right but
instead just like well this Nate's doing
too good over here I'm gonna place them
here right in the same Lane as an enemy
so it's just making it too easy alright
so obviously he doesn't stop the
checkmate correctly alright so so what's
a move that doesn't stop the checkmate
but kinda looks like it does well it
attacks the Queen but it doesn't stop
the checkmate okay so let's see so I got
the seven move one excellent okay but
let's see some other ideas alright what
if he plays h6 to stop it now it's gonna
take us more than eight moves seven
moves to win but but let's get a
foreseen win here okay so we have three
different ways we can take on f7 right
the Queen the knight or the bishop which
one should we do it with Knight takes
excellent
all right at least that's my story
Yassir might disagree but night takes is
great I mean it's gotta be all right
hashtags night takes all right so he
doesn't want to lose his Queen right I
don't want to lose my queen so I'm going
to move it doesn't matter yeah so so
you're thinking about winning the Queen
right now when I'm thinking about
winning the nine billion dollar piece
the King okay so all right so so he
doesn't want to lose this Queen because
let's say he plays eh there's a very
simple way to win the Queen which may
earn that may not be the best move with
Knight to d6 shucks
okay that wins the enemy Queen so he
plays east seven here now can we
actually check make this guy or can we
just like take all the stuff double
check looks good to me
and when you're in double check you can
only move the King all other options off
the table okay so he can go here or here
doesn't matter every well he wants to go
in the corner because it is really
scared that's where you go when you're
scared all right and now even I could
see the checkmate so this is very
exciting hopefully everybody else gained
at home
all right so this is a move I oh oh
interesting so every night move wins
even the rain is face nine of seven is
the only one that doesn't mate
and of course that's the one I was going
to recommend guys now now we have now we
have the Queen come down and checkmate
okay so it's a lot of fun alright so
there's one other move black can make in
this scenario and it's just get oh well
we're not gonna go over that one so
Yasir Yasir she's just the best move
obviously Queen takes Knight and that
just it does lose a queen but hey like
the King's worth so much more than the
Queen so you're still alive and fighting
but yeah the other move that doesn't
work but you could try is a rook to e8
alright so now we got a lot of different
checks we can play here so and obviously
this one does lead to a checkmate a very
cool checkmate
the smothered mate excellent Queen takes
f7 check King retreats this corner and
he's got it where a queen check you're
like what I can just take it and but
look at that you're all you're smothered
you're you're surrounded by your pieces
so all when you're surrounded all you
have to do is deliver a check to him and
then he's done for so he's done for ya
like checkmate so a lot of cool
different checkmates you can do from
that position all right so now one kid
decided hey I'm sick of comer being
everybody in like such short order I'm
gonna put up a big fight okay so let's
see how long he can last here it is
longer than eight moves all right e4 e5
Bishop c4 Bishop c5 Knight f3 so if I
was playing black or I'm not playing
black if I was playing white in this
position what move would I really really
be hoping that black plays in this
position it's the worst move in all of
chess a Queen h4 that'd be too easy of a
win
f6 you might as well when you play up
six you might as well play Queen to h4
here so just it's like horrible okay so
you can just punish them check if they
block the check check for King the king
and the rook here King f8 so take it
alright so now I he decides that
threading the G pawn instead of the F
pawn I don't know how good that is so
which piece of blacks is inadequately
defended in this
position done night yeah so just take
all the stuff check check King there
alright be three so now he thinks he's
going going places he's threatening
Queen takes and Queen takes Chuck but I
got my own checks so Bishop check King
here H for King here and now I only see
a mate in three here instead of a
missile mate in - so what move should
white play in this position and it's
everything you ever dreamed about it's a
check and a capture so take it and now
can you be better than me
I miss the checkmate that's a good I am
haha so all I think about is like but
you guys think about winning that Queen
instead of instead of checkmating the
king you know so what move can actually
just chuck made them Queen f5 checkmate
and said I'm like I got to win that
Queen and then I'm like you know maybe
checkmates better alright so that's how
you can win in short order okay you have
your your opponent play your they're
pieces where they don't belong in the
same Lane as your enemy Queen or Bishop
and you just take it and you're feeling
good alright well you got one last game
here and we decided make it a long game
alright so so we'll see how players
rated about what about 1100 play when
they're not losing in eight moves okay
so let's check it out here is our hero
white or black
alright hero Josh is white all right all
right so II for black plays the Sicilian
alright so they you know attack
but yeah just because you know you're
not gonna win an eight moves doesn't
mean you know you can't make some good
attacks right off the bat you know d3
excellent you see you play d3 after you
got the bishop out of the pawn chain a
good is he playing all right east six
good night up three night f6 Bishop III
you know what yeah I mean just castle
castle when you can you know you know
you want to so you might as well alright
so ii five so not a good movie five
weekend this pawn and created a hole
here okay so not recommended e5 so now I
guess Castle
you could play h3 here
preventing out the bishop from getting
the g4 but castles fine alright so he
gets as a knight in here so after Castle
Knight to g5 okay like me yep
yeah cuz d5 is a mess here
yeah I guess he had a chance to come on
in this f7 but yeah so so if I was bad
for many reasons many reasons huh
all right Knight to d4 hoping that'll
take like that I guess and fork to your
Bishop and the knight but instead he
takes and yeah I got his knight in here
so Knight takes Bishop takes and now he
gets Bishop to g4 in but no fear so when
he played a bish about you left the pawn
undefended
so after h3 he retreats and it protects
f7 here so let's see if we had a tactic
here it doesn't look like it all right
all right
h3 bishop so now we got now we got the
take so so black really should have
taken this night here and so after Queen
takes up three you're threatening
checkmate
and you're also threatening bishop takes
but you can just play queen here and
defend both all right
but you know he played back and now
takes takes and now White's got a great
move you know see a check play the check
and Kings got a move yeah the life is
good for a white here so he's got to
defend the pawn so he does pawns are
really good at protecting other pawns
because then you don't need your big
heavy pieces to you know just depend
upon all right so Queen attacks Bishop
retreats King goes back g4 so now he's
moving pawns in front of the his King
kind of risky
and the night up there eight-six much
better than f6 huh
if f6 has played what move would wait
gallantly play 96 check the fork right
all right so so he knows it
good Java David not playing f6
yeah and not and I can just go back yeah
alright so Bishop e7 so he's trying to
trying to give it that bishop going here
h5 g 5 alright Queen d7 it's getting
intense here all right so Knight H 2
alright so so what's a what's a move
that a black a play - maybe just scare
white it might not be good but but it's
scary
what's a scary move for black here yeah
yeah I don't know what would you really
play the head in the game yeah sir
yeah excellent yeah it's scary right
yeah excellent good yeah I mean yeah if
you would be you know scared by a move
then just play it right if you know so
so good so alright but instead he plays
up everybody's favorite f6 all right so
not good f4 so he keeps moving marching
up his uh his protectors so so the
knight basically has to has to do the
job of three pawns here so takes try to
break it open but he doesn't let him get
broken open he advances his pawn to f5
at the expense of a pawn here now you
have tax the Queen so now the Queen
instead of being down here
menacing just doing nothing all right
so takes bishop takes
Queen e2 so Bishop attacks the knight
Knight f3 g6 so Queen alright yeah on
the same land as the King now so it
could get could get scary if he's not
careful but black is gonna do them a
favor as I get off that G line okay you
should have kept this because now you
know you have dreams of maybe getting
your rook down there and uh you know
doing a super pin here but alright so
he's on the H file here if we can bring
it back up alright
so takes take so now he's got the G file
open but he puts his rook on the F file
here c3 bishop attacks the bishop clean
up so Bishop takes he's only got one way
to take it back with the pawn and now
he's going for this pawn so captures
captures of course he'll he'll take here
give him double pawns but now his King
can get checked on the diagonal so he
might want to watch out for that alright
so he plays rook to e4 so he does get
checked on the diagonal here King to g1
so unfortunately because of this awkward
placement of the King from the beginning
his rooks can never connect and he can
never really put the hurt on a white
here alright so he takes the pawn but so
we just took a pawn however the King in
the center doesn't look so so hot right
now so what does white play to try to
finish up the game here
just take it the only thing we can take
right Quinn takes D six check he's got
one move and it's not good and check
King on the line and rook to be one
Queen King on the same Lane the same
thing that he wanted to do to a polite
but could never accomplish because his
rooks were never connected white can
because he got castled and was safe
until he rushed up all his pawns and
that's game Oh game over
okay so that's that's what a real game
should look like instead of a a move on
catastrophe okay